oh my god oh my god the faces
i like it very much indeed and i
definitely know who i want to be
i'm gonna throw up the second one down
on the left
i'm with you the rest of them
what about the fourth on the left well
oh but i've seen people that look
top right i know that man that's the
assistant vice principal in my high
school i'm 90
sure oh okay all right then tell me you
don't know that human that's definitely
a person
someone should be a student do you i i
picked a student because you guys said
you weren't i really got
this is a bra that i'm wearing you get
money
by beating the crap out of students why
well do i just beat up students
welcome to my class lord minion minions
oh my god how did you pull such a big
skateboard out of your anus
oh my god left click is punched just
like back in my day
hi oh hey are you bringing an early
lunch
yeah actually it's called a knuckle
sandwich
oh no i'm thinking about this
oh i killed jessica oh no
oh dear oh she disappeared nothing
happened there's no body you can't prove
what did
you didn't see anything oh no oh
whoa was me okay i'm fine now
what do we do i pull just can't
look at me grandma my game just changed
sizes that's what you want to see
holy sweets jesus wow look at these tony
hawk skills
damn roots top six 360 shoving
jessica's body oh she's back oh hey oh
you're back
are you jessica oh you know what they
wanted to come back to my classroom
this is what you get for learning if you
want to be in school it's not safe
why are you beating up that poor girl
mission accomplished why did you not
stop us my mission
drive school bus into lake school lunch
man get your skateboard out
of a skateboard well you should get one
i'm delightful
all right oh god he has a bow and arrow
oh no how did he get a bow and arrow
i'm going to beat your ass ah freak out
i'm going to beat your ass
you can't shoot us both you can't shoot
us both oh
frick how do we win uh well my mission
says i want to drive the school bus into
the lake
so oh hey one of you guys gets another
cool thing in here i get it
oh that's a jet pack how do you sure
see it it's my dude
there we go who peter's ass oh my god i
would have
whatever is this supposed to be
happening what happened
i got washed into the sky
all right wait you have a bunch of like
high tier [ __ ] this seems like
it's just laying around in the school
for the most part all this stuff is just
like is that an
air cannon did you launch me into the
sky with you
yes i think so you know kind of stuff
that's just normally lying around
schools
where uh where did you guys go i'm in
the library of the school
uh-huh i'm also in the library learning
huh
i'm heading for the yellow air oh hey oh
god
don't don't let him get you he he can't
because i'm
got a jet it's not working i thought
that he wouldn't be able to do it when i
was
flying take some of this and one of
these please
hold on wait no you can't escape
chef got a jet pack ah no
why oh god that seems really unfair
yeah come on student let us beat you up
what what is
oh you killed him i killed him he's dead
our work here is done
what does this arrow mean i'm so
confused i don't know
i also have the mission of driving the
school bus into the lake i think that's
the teacher mission
my mission is wait no i've got the same
mission so i guess we're competing
together all right let's go get on the
school bus kid
it's time to go do you have the school
bus where's the school bus
i see it there it is eyes on the school
bus where where is it
woof other side of the school where i
beat up that kid
oh [ __ ] and then and then um wait
hey wait i oh what oh oh
you ready you ran me over oh well mark
found it again
i found it out of the school i feel like
you misled me about where the school bus
is
on the other side of the school to the
left if you're leaving out the back of
the school
you know what take it all right thank
you how do you even get on the bus
press f to free your hands and then
press e oh
uh grandma can you get in the bus
uh africa careful it's very deadly
tires on the front there's two tires on
the back but there's two tires in the
front
look man just like how school buses are
ma'am
i can't i can't i can't only one person
could be in a vehicle but you can take
one of the other cars take one of the
cars
take a car oh hell yeah mark it's dead
ahead let's go
all right your character when she runs
just like the scariest zombie
like ever i've never seen a grandmother
so i'm like holding my side right now i
see that
dead ahead oh this is not a liquid this
is um this is an
ocean it's a great lake oh you're right
oh
wait i don't think we could drive over
those you're right here we go
oh great lake send it baby
i sent it oh i don't know if that counts
as a lake
does it wait
shark shark
shark oh hey guys how's it going i'm
going to punch a shark
oh are we going after him oh wait
[Applause]
i've got lunch
i'm coming to help you buddy all right
i'm coming
look like meat's back on the menu boys
that looks delicious child did you
capture that shark yes
it's a lie now of course it's ow
sorry sorry you think you can take me
i've bested a great white
can i oh i can throw oh no oh no the
shark
oh you mine yeah
my my oh my god i threw him
i know hey douche
like playing catch with the kid
physical education what the hell
happened oh
that's a blue that is yeah it's fine
oh good throw grandma
there you go go along
i don't think you can actually grab it
out of midair i think you were right
yeah you're right of course you're going
to place a contingency into this game to
grab at midair
my arms are in i think i still hang on
are you broken throw it
send it my way past me yeah well that's
gone well
oh my god there's this there's a rocket
ship oh my gosh guys come here
i'm on the way hang on i'm gonna break
and enter into this house and see what
kind of
supplies i have because my jet packs are
gone apparently no wait i was pressing
the wrong button for just back
um use a lighter wait a minute yeah so
i told you whenever you beat up the kids
you get money here follow me bob
i didn't want to show you guys this but
you've earned it why what have we done
to earn it
i'm in the coop in the oh god you really
can go right in there
i thought you were being metaphorical no
where did you go wayne
right here right here doesn't describe
the joke shop turn left
i see i see hey kids playing football
have fun i'll have fun playing football
you know i used to
i used to be quarterback oh god they
actually want me
you'll never get me alive are you guys
still by the joke shop i haven't even
gone in it yet i was
busy playing rugby oh my god
hey i'm dead now thank you
there's a hole i'm going in the hole i
must go in
oh god
if you fell in the i'm dead can i please
don't drive the bus into the hole all
right i'm taking the boss into the why
are you driving the bus into the hole
why not and where's the hole wait
there's a giant hole
right here doesn't mean anything that's
right
uh there he goes oh okay um
yeah all right jessica's back i'm gonna
take jessica out again
okay okay she's fine she's 100 percent
fine actually
i'm unclear on how this steamroller
works uh
you've got a steamroller come get rolled
with this i don't want to bro
i've died many times my god she's
flat look everything it's like willy
wonka rules up in here everything's fine
you're so fine don't you feel mine
that's exactly what happens in real life
when you get steamrolled i'm fairly
certain
i'm better now are you oh apparently
oh damn it [ __ ] you're like a goddamn 16
year old hercules
damn you're strong hey but how do you
mess with this
uh wade
well this this stream roller seems to be
quite useless so i'm just gonna put it
in this hole here
all right oh the bus is already in the
hole well
well glad you enjoyed your shopping trip
i am dead
so far in the ocean listen i'm going to
the rocket ship
all right can i watch i suppose it's
behind the soccer field from nowhere it
is
well no one was explaining anything to
me so i just thought i'd be a good
citizen here
fair enough i see you skating down there
ruth ruth
the notorious rbg that's what they call
me that's what you
are i guess i'll oh my god i bought
something called lighter and look what
it is
it's an aerosol can and a lighter oh
fire up if i could just get my taint on
this i think i'd balance
oh no oh i got i did it holy crap
bob i did it oh look at you i did it i
got my taint right on there
i'm trying to launch you into space my
dude but all right well whenever you do
it
i'm ready oh use the rocket yeah maybe
don't send it to space without me which
i don't know i'll leave i don't i don't
think it's working
hmm was there a button problem maybe
through your hands and then press
it just says next mission dive oh no
it just says in the bottom left you use
a lighter and a launch rocket that's all
i get
wait do you know how to do it no i don't
we never i never got this to work
oh hey mark hello i really need to go
get myself a jet pack
pretty sweet skateboards nothing
compared to it i don't seem to be able
to burn weight
this is a real sad show gang maybe these
are just uh mark do you have any
fireworks no not anymore
i only have the one i can't even shoot
you with arrows you're you're protected
look at your invisible force field look
at me more powerful than you could ever
imagine
i've ascended beyond it
[Laughter]
got him i'm gonna look for a lake i
don't think there's a lake
the pool is the closest i've found to a
lake that's not a lake that's a pool
there's a lake i see the lake where's
where well
the school bus wasn't completely boned i
would say excellent job
oh is it still in the hole yeah it's
just in the hole
all right gotta make some money here
real quick are you beating the [ __ ] out
of students to make money or is that an
adult
oh okay sure no i could also beat the
[ __ ] out of students to make money
can we blow up the bus with fireworks
probably all right i gotta go beat up
some kids where are you
come here give me your money give me
your lunch money oh
okay well i didn't what what
why are we both naruto running hey bob
i'm oh yeah
i run away
yeah why uh why is this happening
get her all right all right you took the
money oh you grab oh you grabbed her
oh you can grab them can i drown them
no that seems like a hard no maybe maybe
if you bring them in the
in the fountain they can't run away
though and then i think i might have
blown the bus
up good i'm gonna go i'm gonna go get my
uh
look at my jetpack oh my god are you
getting your ass beat by a little kid
no no you just punched the lunch the
lunch man
i happened to be low on health i was
only one hit away so we i killed three i
mean i beat up
three oh pogo stick yeah what else is
this
the more stuff you have on your wheel
the harder it is to do anything oh yeah
okay bus i think is now destroyed it'll
respawn shortly hopefully
hey mark i don't want to see me just
wing the hell out of this kid with a
baseball bat all right but first i gotta
lasso
this one okay holy [ __ ] all right you
hold him down i'll beat him
you keep that last two on there come on
i got him
you like that yeah how do you like that
one your ass beat by your grandma don't
walk in here
you walk away you walk away right now i
think you're losing
nah i'm fine i think i don't think i can
oh
man he's a feisty one can i beat the
hell out of this all hell
already in the inventory they don't help
it you don't help this wheel sucks oh
hey the bus is back
all right i'm going to drive it into the
lake what did i just pick up
spray oh my god i can do graffitis
seems like you're driving toward that
pond or pool
delay are you talking about the lake you
talking about the lake
mark are you going to the lake i'm going
to the lake i'm at the lake i'm in the
lake
which way is the lake uh north i don't
know
did that count sure did
no actually it didn't i think i needed
to wait maybe the arrow is above those
kids heads because we got to pick them
up
and then drive them into the lake oh
mayhaps you are
correct all right wait can you blow up
that bus again it's back
it's back never mind do you guys want to
buy my truck ow
how's it going not it's good
not fun when you use my head to bounce
no it's fun for me
oh i'm gonna die yeah that's fair enough
give me your money
give me your money please give me your
money give me your money i don't have
them give me your help your money give
me your money they have your money give
me your money please don't give me your
money
give me your money give me your money
give me your money
give me your money i think mark would
like your money he didn't give me any of
his
money give me your money going for a
triple bouncer no oh my god the school
bus drives like a big old school bus
glad they nailed the driving in this
game yeah that's so realistic
give me your money give me your money
mark there's so much money lying around
thank you for earning me this money did
you
take my money yes well
now slappy's gonna have to pogo on your
head hey what's up give me your money
you're here for these kids
i i'm trying give me your money i think
maybe our mission is glitched
mission to prevent the school bus from
diving into the lake it says now
give me your money give me your money i
don't have any of your money give me
your money so maybe i should try driving
the school bus into the lake
all right give me your money oh god give
me your money don't let him touch me
again give me your money i got you ed
don't worry do you think the bus can
protect you give me your money i'm not
in the bus douchebag i'm not talking to
you
i'm talking to the one that needs to
give me their money position to be
straight up my ass coming for your money
does that help
is that helping i think that helps oh
money don't
take that money it's mine oh money no
ah sweet thanks
[Applause]
that's what you get look at how
perfectly that worked out for the hey
mark
yes mark hey mark mark yes mark mark
hello mark yes all right
okay you see you see what i'm getting
dad you see what i'm doing
that's inappropriate you see you see how
they're getting bigger that's
inappropriate
i'm stopping you ah stop that that took
you so long to accomplish
there's gonna be to show you what
pogoing really truly is i wasn't trying
to bounce on your head i was watching
you and then
i got you on my first strike that's what
it
sure yeah okay yeah try me hey we failed
i succeeded throw a nerd into the pool
okay what's the pool and what's the lake
got it maybe they're hey money god
that's my money is there like a pool
near the gymnasium or something in this
school
i don't know you think i work at this
place just some mass murderer that found
his way into the school that's all i am
this guy's a nerd wait why can't i pick
up these nerds
come here are all the kids nerds or only
some of only some of the kids
some of them are like highlighted i'm
trying it all right i'll go for the
other one where's the pool
what is this nerd somebody tell me
i'm gonna pretend the fountain is the
pool you all are very
dumb nerd
is this the pool this is the library i
got him counted i did it win a fight
against an athlete come here douche hole
uh i this nerd is now part of me this
nerd has become
one with me come with me nerd oh my god
i hear the pogoing from come here
very crappy you cannot beat me now
i've got a naruto fan here that really
is going to teach you the business
yeah wait just don't you be
fighting any athletes what are you
dragging around with you is that an
athlete
this is my nerd all right there he is
i'm gonna go beat up some athletes yeah
okay don't i think not
bob don't who's taking pictures that's
the side of the jet pack makes
no wait think about this don't don't oh
you will pay for that with your money
give me your money no
think i can't follow you into the sky
yes
i will show you the true power of flight
yeah i almost got you i'm catching up
no no no no nope nope nope
goodbye no
where's the hey can you guys tell me
what are you guys the math teacher bob
you teach math right
probably marcus there's still a nerd
yeah he's carrying the nerve permanently
you have a problem with it
makes them smarter legal reasons yes for
anecdotal reasons no
no legality all right fine you know are
you
supposed to figure out where the math
teacher's house is i don't know
oh i can't i can't grab anyone else
you hurt my nerd you killed me
but you hurt man come here money hey get
off me i need this money come here you
wait you know you removed my jet pack
and i'm going to grab you
got them no all right this nerd's going
in the pool
i still haven't ever found the pool i'm
about to hey hey let me throw you in the
pool let me throw it
this is what you get let me throw you in
it's okay
just let me throw you in and then we'll
be done that'll be it that'll be the end
of it that'll be the end of it
hey that'll be the end of it hey dude
deal fair is fair you let me throw you
in the pool that'll be the end of it
oh it'll be the end of it no please
it's in the end and now i think you're
with me forever
oh no i could oh and i've got him
so you uh yeah that'll be the end of it
wow
that will be the end of it how do you
feel about that
can we go in the water now point his ass
at me all right yeah
yeah yeah get him in there like that
yeah five alarm rectum over here
[Music]
do we force respawn out of here what do
we do wait i want to have friends
i don't know how to i don't know how we
did that
put that down did that kill you no
l is forceful oh we can beat the [ __ ]
out of each other no i l
yeah bob do you want me to try to get
you into the other yeah
can we oh no okay wait you're going to
come over here i need to get bob
stuck on me wait come on all right if i
i i get you stuck on me now you're stuck
okay and then i get out of the whoa
okay i freed myself for a second and it
was as you were grabbing me again
that i zapped okay get it thing out and
then i'm gonna grab you right as you do
it
no that's not it all right well i went
wait
what the hell okay finish way to go wade
way
to go way to go there was a timer at the
bottom the timer ran out bob couldn't
see
the underworld let's see the underverse
way to go
wait i guess it'll never happen i'll
remake it hang on
this is a good game guys if you guys
want to see a trick you should come up
to my classroom
just follow the clicking sound my my my
yeah can you see up grandma's skirt you
like that don't like it well i see it
mark are you coming i'm coming all right
oh
hey look i did tricks good
that's great all right you want to go in
the pool yeah let's go into the
afterlife
come on all right and then
up and then okay wait you count it down
and i'll grab you as soon as you shoot
this is definitely going to work three
two one
that did not work okay all right i think
you got i think you got encapsulated
holy [ __ ] all right we got sucked in by
wade's thing first
i i don't think i can grab you for some
reason i think with with with uh
bob stuck like this i can't well i'm
just gonna
i'm just gonna die all right we're gonna
flop around a little bit huh
bob can you break free somehow yeah i
can get out of here you're in some kind
of trouble
oh no oh god
oh no can you pick me up out too i can't
seem to move
oh help okay thank you you saved my life
bob when he shoots grab him yeah that's
i think the way
three two one go
let's go back inside and i think being
inside may have helped you
like right here i think i think just
having the ceiling that might have been
like a one in a million bug we'll see if
it might have been all right three two
one
go holy
what try it on me again let's see if we
can do it on me
try me you wouldn't dare three two okay
oh no oh god three two
one what all right
oh okay okay all right
oh my god it's human centipede wait you
can throw me wait you put me through the
wall hang on
shove me through the wall yeah wait yeah
that was yeah
once you're stuck into the wall spam e
bob once you can see nothing
well mark can let me go mark can let me
go that's right that's like goodbye hey
i'm in the okay you're going into the
naughty universe
oh god you just fly through me do oh my
god
here's the shaft it looks so good
it's exactly the shape of a poop just
like i always thought
oh the hole goes deeper than oh no i'm
back in the hole
well now i'm dead mark put me back in
uh all right do me uh okay
yeah do you want to go back down mark
no i'm okay i'm gonna just flatten some
students all right
the student's too strong you know of all
things in this game the steamroll is my
favorite i just
i just have to say that that is that is
genius so funny
oh gosh hilarious so you guys completed
a mission i'm gonna complete one
just so that we're tied that the game
doesn't end again i mean how much longer
are we gonna play it
forever okay summon rain
where was the jet pack oh there's a jet
pack right here mark in the science
laboratory
oh is it where i'm hearing this
we have to go into a small space and all
gravity gun each other simultaneously i
don't even know where the gravity
is are you upstairs oh yeah upstairs the
science room is upstairs on the end by
the
library i see there should be a gravity
going i'm coming back
and i just killed the way this i found
it so
what are we doing with this quite small
let's go to the principal's office wait
let's go to the principles
all right hi princy sir we need your
office okay
oh wait yes so do we want to see what
happens so to grab you right click
and then left click and then hold right
click
okay so grab me um
[Laughter]
okay is anyone doing anything
no i'm doing nothing i'm just talking
about right click watch
as well how'd you let go that was your
brother
oh we're all good yes where'd uh wade
where'd you go
sorry i you guys lost me to the edge
hang on i do need to trigger
something real quick uh-huh where did
you guys end up
uh where are you we'll come to you i'm
floating over the joke shop right now
head toward that corner
oh i see you are you at the house all
right
yeah he's down here yeah okay
all right so oh
oh my god oh my goodness
oh oh oh
oh oh oh what oh
to the higher to the higher roof to the
higher roof oh
what's um happening to all the people
that work down there
i think they're dead someone pick me up
first and then i'll be in wait spot and
then everyone just hold on tight
no one let go oh god trying to grab this
thing out
is the biggest pain in my ass i've
figured out the wheel
okay is that what you did i tried to
grab
yeah i tried to go there there we go and
away we go
okay okay okay
we are ascending
why why did we lose weight what happened
someone let go of me or something i
wouldn't knock it out i went into the
ocean
oh it's the worst speed all right
so much all right what oh god if you
look up my skirt it's an actual
nightmare
all right wait mark have you seen inside
my skirt you should definitely see
inside
no no no mark you gotta you gotta see
what's in there i'm okay
if you steal the football they're so
angry yeah they get a little pissed
hey what's going on here kids hey you be
careful
oh did i score i think i scored the
money
those kids had oh you took all my money
well i knew i was to get it eventually
and that's what you deserved
don't even try you could never catch me
ah you got me but just wait until i
fly through the air all right waiting i
am woof hang on wait for it
i didn't realize you're right behind me
bob let's play catch
oh nice
oh wow that's really long holy crap
oh no got him no all right i'll catch
him
all right go along i'm lost
well that's sad i would like to do a
trio again i think we should do a trio
of gravity again and just not let go all
right okay i will never let go
i'm coming you're gonna have to let go
of your stranger wade
i've got you i am never gonna
how high can we go no one let go never
let go not letting go
i would never let go it's it's giving me
the each interact button
periodically and i really want to push
it and it's just free hands to interact
for me so i don't know i think we're
sending into this involved letting go of
the gravity gun are we going to heaven
i think so i think this is our time
we're not a camp yet we're still
uh ascending yeah we still go this
entire town is built around
a school in the middle of an island in
the middle of nowhere surrounded by
mountains
yeah i think it's a crater this is
definitely like a volcano a super
volcano something so it's like a
futuristic dystopian thing where for the
record if you try to jet pack this high
you hit like a ceiling
so we've already breached the ceiling of
which you can jet pack all right
well there's got to be a roof right i
think yeah got to hit the end eventually
i see if you look up the the the it's
like a glass dome it's like in fortnight
you know when the sky broke
a long time ago back when fortnite i
don't know but i
believe it popular i want to fly all the
way to the to the sun up there
yeah well i don't know if we have a lot
of directional control i think we're
just
victim to the whim of cruel gods that
laugh at us but we are
very high up actually a mechanic that's
intended and it's possible to go to
another
planet i hope so if the devs are
watching and that's not a thing
make it you need to add some a
destination that that
rewards you for this yeah i bet we're
close i think we're getting close
do you see definitely i think so too
we're definitely passing some clouds
we're coming up on the clouds
yeah oh yeah no we're we're i think
we're about to uh
discover what it means to go further
beyond
uh all right guys see on the other side
i guess
yeah across the streams let's do this
huh
[Music]
we've ascended into the heavens
broken the surly bonds of gravity and
are ascending
deep into the starless sky yes it truly
is a void
empty man that island is pretty big
though in terms of like
relative to the size of the whole planet
so is that very round
mountain range well it only looks round
from here actually if you look at the
mountains it just they look like they've
got intersecting lines
and in some sort of a shape like an
unholy symbol of some kind
we're still i think ascendant yeah we're
definitely getting very gradually
smaller
i wonder if i pointed you guys down
if we would ascend below you know if
wade was pointed down and then
grabbed me if we would go the other way
we should try that we should try a
different arrangement
when you had weighed up he was up and
grabbed me from
right right right right if we put him
below
you want to try right right right right
right yeah are we ready to
let go are we gonna let go and see what
happens yeah i think
can we try and launch each other
laterally and see how far
all right like horizontally yeah i'm
gonna stick my
my mouse to the horizon right on the
line three
two one go oh
i got launched there's no gravity in
space i forgot
i hit i am going down i seem to have hit
an end
i've stuck i i hit the edge of the
universe and locked in place
exactly straight down into a mountain
range mark how small
this is the circle maybe a couple inches
on my screen right now
it's it's just an eye staring at me i
see the mountain
oh
all right i'm gonna force respawn see if
it takes me my journey for my soul back
to the mortal plane let's see what
happens
i can't respond i am stuck outside of
existence
am i stuck here then too i think so it
still says
l to respawn is that a lie i'm pressing
l
oh no we're locked in i don't even have
an inventory
i can't even tab i don't i think we've i
think we found
uh a new type of travel yeah we truly
went
further beyond and more cursed
[Music]
you